the night sky seems peaceful and orderly
but in reality stars are careening
through the galaxy at speeds of hundreds
of thousands of kilometers per hour not
bound by static formations but changing
neighborhoods constantly
fortunately space is big and so the
stars of the milky way are very unlikely
to hit us
unfortunately they don't have to hit
anything to make us have a really bad
time on earth
and there are already stars starting to
get very close
[Music]
to understand how dangerous stars are to
us we need to talk about gravity
gravity attracts every piece of matter
to every other piece of matter in the
universe
you are attracted by an atom a million
light years away and vice versa
luckily this force gets weaker over
distance and it also depends on how
massive something is so things that are
close and are very massive are more
attractive winning the cosmic tug of war
this way massive things define how
smaller things behave around them
the sun makes up 99.75 percent of all
the mass in the solar system and so it
shapes the behavior and orbits of
everything else in it
billions of years ago after the sun was
born the solar system was a chaotic and
dangerous place as the planets were
formed from countless little pieces that
collided constantly but over the eons a
stable balance emerged
today most planets and asteroids have
settled into safe and predictable orbits
we have the inner and outer planets the
asteroid and kuiper belt and at the edge
the oort cloud a giant sphere of comets
orbiting slowly in cold storage
we really don't want this balance to be
disturbed
if another star came too close to us its
gravity would pull on everything in the
solar system like a spoiled toddler
messing up the pleasant order of the
planets and asteroids and comets
this isn't some imaginary danger
some 70 000 years ago a red dwarf brown
dwarf binary system passed through the
or cloud and messed things up it might
even have sent a deadly onslaught of
asteroids our way but it could take two
million years until those visitors from
the orc cloud arrive in the inner solar
system
but there's a much bigger problem on the
horizon gliese 710 a red dwarf with
about half the mass of the sun is
currently headed towards the solar
system in about a million years it'll
pass through the york cloud and become
the brightest star in the night sky
a close flyby like this would unfold
over hundreds of thousands of years
disrupting the orbits of millions of
objects in the oort cloud considerably
if we're unlucky it will trigger a new
period of planetary bombardment similar
to the early solar system
the night sky could be filled with
comets and asteroids raining down on the
inner solar system
the larger ones could cause dinosaur
level mass extinctions and would be bad
for the stock market
but it could get much worse the galaxy
is an intense place and stars get close
to each other regularly
so it is possible that a star could come
much closer and not just pass us but fly
directly through the inner solar system
this would be very bad in the extreme
the chance of another star colliding
with the sun is astronomically unlikely
but that isn't what we're worried about
if another star were to pass by about as
close as the earth is from the sun it
could easily eject the earth from the
solar system
the odds of such an event are estimated
to be around one in one hundred thousand
in the next five billion years
small but not absurdly so
as we discussed in another video there
seem to be billions of rogue planets
doing their own thing in the galaxy and
this is one way to make them so if this
were to happen with an average red dwarf
what would happen on earth
kicking earth out of the solar system
as the star enters the solar system a
small orangish dot appears in the sky
that grows bigger and bigger for months
eventually becoming visible during the
day
it would get bigger and much brighter
than the moon
too bright to look at directly
the night sky would be filled with an
eerie red glow
after a few months it would start
shrinking again
but so would the sun
over a few years the sun slowly grows
smaller in the sky and with it warmth
and light start to dissipate all around
the world as the days turn dark the
final winter of humanity would begin
the polar ice caps begin to grow and
spread while plants shrivel and die
forests freeze and animals die in droves
as the earth passes the orbit of mars
the average surface temperature has
plummeted to near minus 50 degrees
celsius
from space earth begins to look like an
icy moon the blue green surface becoming
the pale grey white of death
as global infrastructure breaks down
people huddle together indoors burning
what they can for warmth as the
temperature continues to drop counting
the days until they'll be out of food
which no longer grows
everybody living at the surface is
living on borrowed time
by the time earth reaches jupiter's
orbit surface temperatures sink to minus
150 degrees celsius lower than the
coldest ever recorded temperatures in
antarctica
needless to say by now almost everyone
is dead
without the energy from sunlight to
evaporate water clouds don't form and
the water cycle stops
the polar ice caps eventually touch at
the equator and the oceans become
covered in a thick layer of ice
as more and more of its heat leaks out
more water freezes onto the bottom of
the ice sheet the concentration of salt
in the deep ocean grows poisoning most
animals that survived here
although around hydrothermal vents
communities of extremophiles might adapt
even to these circumstances
deep below the surface some bacteria
would not notice much of any of this as
they're still kept warm by the
radioactive decay of elements in the
earth's core
as the earth reaches the orbit of pluto
and the kuiper belt the sun is still the
brightest star in the sky but it's one
among many with stars now visible during
the day
the temperature is now barely 40 degrees
celsius above absolute zero below the
freezing temperature of the gases in the
atmosphere
a weird spectacle enjoyed by no one
unfortunately unfolds as the atmosphere
turns into nitrogen and then oxygen snow
over a few years it's deposited into an
icy 10 meter thick sheet all over the
planet's surface with only a thin
whisper of gas remaining
the frozen corpses of flora and fauna
are buried beneath them as earth leaves
the solar system it becomes a rogue
planet
traveling alone through the dark
lifeless and in solitude
but weirdly enough there is hope
humanity would not be surprised by this
potential extinction event we'd notice
it thousands of years in advance
there's not a lot we could do to stop a
star but we could prepare
most of us would perish but a few
million could survive in huge artificial
complexes powered by geothermal and
nuclear energy possibly even fusion if
we can learn to use the ice around us
for power
here humanity might survive for hundreds
of thousands of years
at some point we would become used to
our circumstances and new generations
would watch documentaries in disbelief
about the time we had our own star and
could walk the surface of earth
and at some point we might decide to
look for another home
if the earth were lucky enough to pass
by another star with a habitable planet
we could try to make a fresh start the
space flight oddly enough would become
very easy without the atmosphere in the
way
so it's not unthinkable that the last
survivors would leave earth behind and
try again on a new planet around a new
star
maybe one day thousands of years later
the descendants of humanity will tell
legends about earth's ancient past
stories of our lost home of a mysterious
icy planet
floating alone and empty through the
dark of space
so basically the key to humanity's
survival is learning about what we'll be
dealing with well we'd better get
cracking then our friends from brilliant
are the perfect coaches on the way to
becoming more science savvy
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and app that makes science accessible in
a practical way more than 60 interactive
courses give you the tools to crack
problems in maths logic and engineering
all by yourself
instead of a classic lecture format
brilliant uses storytelling code writing
and hands-on problems to keep you
entertained and engaged this way a small
daily challenge can build up to real
long-term understanding of science and
achieving your stem goals
in a nutshell brilliant surprises you
and keeps you on your toes all while
sneaking some knowledge into your head
without your really noticing write up
our annie really
to get a fresh perspective on science go
to brilliant.org slash nutshell and sign
up for free and there's an extra perk
for kurtz out viewers the first 200
people to use the link get 20 off their
annual membership which lets you view
all the daily problems in the archives
and unlock every course
brilliant helps you end your day a
little smarter still the best
preparation for the future we can think
of
[Music]
[Music]